hey youtubers is Charlie so special
bonus video just because the Game of
Thrones finale is coming up a lot of you
been asking about Ozora hi the night's
king this is gonna be all about that
especially some things that George R
Martin just said Martin was talking
about the differences between the show
and the books and clarified something
about the night's king characters that I
think implies something about azor Ahai
- he said that the night's king that
most people refer to the historical
figure is no more alive today probably
no more alive today that is then land
the clever or bran the Builder he said
that in his opinion the night's king is
a historical figure someone from
antiquity that died a long time ago
meaning that the night's king is just a
high-ranking title that the others
passed down somatically I think you can
draw the same conclusion about azor Ahai
- there's no reincarnation or anything
like that it's just that the forces of
the red God
choose their champion just like the
others choose their champion whenever
they need one on the show right now this
person is the champion of the others on
the other side of that coin Melisandre
keeps telling Stannis that he is the
chosen one he's azor Ahai they even let
his blade on fire a couple seasons ago I
know a lot of people are just wondering
as aura high is supposed to have a
flaming blade is that a special sword or
is it just any sword that the chosen
champion of the red God wields that gets
lit on fire the reason this is a big
deal the fact that these titles get
passed down as aura high in the night's
king mean that there's a certain
mortality to these people on the show if
one were to die off like say the night's
king gets killed then the others would
have to choose a new champion you know
meaning we might see characters on the
show take their places the cosmic
conflict that's going on between the
others and the forces of the red God is
called the war for the dawn there's a
certain cyclical nature to the myth is
it you know like one prevails another
Falls and then they start the cycle
again it's like the way some ancient
cultures talk about the Sun chasing the
moon and then the moon chasing the Sun
so when you start talking about the
others the forces of the red God you're
also talking about climate change very
practical real-world events that people
use to build myths on which is remember
that magic does exist in this world so
there are certain magical components to
what's going on to the changing of the
seasons a lot of you guys were asking
after episode 8 if the White Walkers
bring the cold or if they just follow
the seasons like if it's getting cold
and then they come out you know chicken
or the egg
the answer is is that I think that these
two gods do exist there are two separate
entities and their followers are using
their magic to aid in the changing of
seasons but that's all built on natural
processes so like like in real life you
know as the Earth spins you know day and
night have certain durations but if the
Earth's position relative to the Sun
were to change then the duration of
night and day might change and that
would also change the seasons so that's
going on in the Song of Ice and Fire but
but you also have these magical forces
that are trying to influence things one
way or the other I would go so far to
say is like the big climate changes
affect the powers of these relative
forces so as we move towards a more
wintry environment the White Walkers
probably get stronger a really good
example of another series that deals
with this kind of thing is legend decor
and The Last Airbender if you've ever
watched those anime series or cartoons
or have you want to think about them as
certain natural events happen it affects
the relative powers of certain benders
their spiritual alignment the way they
deal with mystical things is very
different from a Song of Ice and Fire
but you get the idea but who is the
night's king and who was azor Ahai so
we'll start with the night's king first
he lived about 8,000 years ago the tale
the night's king starts with the
building of the wall in the 19 castles
chiefly the Nightfort which is the
biggest castle along the wall but is
currently unmanned remember that because
if that was the seat of the Nights Watch
for thousands of years then there might
still be something that they could find
to help them fight White Walkers in
their in present day it's fallen into
disrepair it's just it was too big for
them to maintain so they moved to
smaller castles as the night's watch
itself shrunken manpower the mythical
figure that was the night's king is said
to be the 13th Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch it's rumored that he fell
in love with a female white Walker but
it actually describes her as a pale
sorceress so it's not known whether or
not she was an actual white Walker but
she could have been like their version
of Melisandre it's a big question
because we haven't seen any female White
Walkers on the show as far as we know
they're all the sons of Craster remember
what george RR martin said about the
night's king it's a title that gets
passed down meaning that White Walkers
probably can't reproduce which is why
they need Craster's sacrifices so any of
those White Walkers we see on the show
or probably crashed her sons that he
sacrificed that the White Walkers
perform magic on to turn
to White Walkers the night's king was
said to be the brother of the current
start king the current king of winter
his name was brand the breaker not to be
confused with bran the Builder
so after this night's King figure fell
in love with this pale sorceress what
they call his corpse bride they ruled
over that part of the north from the
Nightfort for a period of about thirteen
years till bran the breaker struck them
down in order to defeat them the start
king of the time had to form an alliance
with the then king-beyond-the-wall named
Sherman that name Sherman might sound
familiar if you've read the books
there's something called the Horn of
Joramun also known as the Horn of winter
that's the mythical object that's
supposed to bring down the wall when
it's blown but it sat in a historical
context when German blew the horn it
woke the Giants and they used the
combined forces to defeat the night's
king so you see how that looks like
what's going on the show right now Jon
Snow forming an alliance with the
king-beyond-the-wall you know in
addition to Stannis is forces to try and
defeat the night's king it's a very
Battlestar type theme you know this has
all happened before this will all happen
again the cyclical nature of history but
as for the actual identity of that
night's king it's still lost to history
a lot of people say it was a Bolton a
lot of people think it was a number a
lot of people think it was that stark
brother what about the original azor
Ahai who was he
his history is a little more complicated
because it gets tied up in that of the
Far East and there's much less recorded
history about what happened there it's
just that most of what we know about
history is recorded by the maesters the
problem with that is there's just
certain parts of the world that they
haven't catalogued quite as well so we
need to travel to a place called et
somewhere we haven't been on the show
but it's the oldest and grandest of Far
Eastern cultures and Song of Ice and
Fire it's one of the few grander
cultures like the ancient Valyria and
Empire the ghiscari Empire that's still
endures to today great civilizations
rise and fall but et has managed to
survive it said that their wealth was so
great that it dwarfed that of ancient
Valyria
so as great as ancient Valyria was with
their dragons the Empire of ET was way
bigger originally it was a bunch of
different territories but then you know
mythical uniter came in just like
ancient China and United all these
separate states his name was Yin he
became the first god emperor of ET the
name of that Empire became
the great Empire of the dawn so see how
that sounds like Melisandre is war for
the dawn between the red God and the
great other this is the culture that
gave birth to the idea of a surah high
in his bloodline a lot of the successors
ended up fighting you know just a very
similar situation to what happened in
Westeros with future Targaryen heirs one
of that original Emperor's descendants
killed his older sister to take the
throne and became known as the
bloodstone Emperor it said that he
practiced Dark Arts torture and
necromancy enslaving his entire race
he took a tiger woman for his bride
feasted on human flesh and cast down the
true gods to worship a black stone that
was said to have fallen from the sky he
became the first high priest of the
Sinister Church of starry wisdom the
funny thing about that is that's like a
real world thing that's part of the
Cthulhu Mythos it said that the
bloodstone Emperor's practices assured
in the long night so you see how this is
like a very different story from what
happened over in Westeros a lot of
people think that the others were the
one that assured in the long night but
in this version of the story it was the
bloodstone Emperor worshipping this
black stone that fell from the sky so
maybe that has something to do with the
origin of the god of the White Walkers
the great other himself it just makes
sense that if you have this religious
war that a single culture invented both
the God in the devil of that story the
story goes on to say though that
despairing the evil had been unleashed
on the earth the maiden made of light a
mythical figure turned her back on the
world and the Lion of night came forward
in all his wroth to punish the
wickedness of men the Lion of night in
this story represents the forces of evil
the others they're great reign of terror
ended when a mythical figure azor Ahai
led the forces of man against them using
light bringer other cultures have
different names for him too there's her
the hero in tar Nefarian and
eldritch shadow chaser so azor Ahai is
not his only name after that happened it
kind of shattered the UT culture though
and they went their different directions
that the great Empire the dawn didn't
completely reform so you see there are a
lot of things going on here magic is
involved but it's a lot of people in
retrospect applying myth to just regular
events like regular Civil War
that being said we still have no idea
what the true origin of the White
Walkers are it could have something to
do with the magic performed by the
bloodstone Emperor with this special
black stone or they could just be
another race that evolved on a planet
but I do think that the Empire of the
dawn and the bloodstone Emperor is the
common origin for azor Ahai the White
Walkers the great other in the red God
remember this all happened before the
rise of Valyria the actual rise of the
Valyrian freehold is said to have been
about five thousand years ago when they
first rose to power the night's king the
building of the wall back to the long
night about eight thousand years ago so
long time before that okay so what does
all that stuff have to do with what's
going on in the show right now what I
think is going to end up happening is is
that by the end of the series the either
the mythical figure of azor Ahai or the
night's king will die and someone on the
show is going to have to replace them
just going based on the information the
show has given us so far
Stannis is azor Ahai as Melisandre has
told him and the night's king is
obviously the champion of the others
Danna Davis said that they've signed all
the main cast through season seven so
far with you know potential for season
eight but that doesn't mean that
everyone is gonna live to the end
Joffrey and Ned Stark
both main cast members so just because
their main cast member doesn't mean that
they're safe pending any rugs being
pulled out from under us you know it
seems like the show has been telling us
that Daenerys and Jon Snow are the two
most important characters on the show
and then you have like a certain cast of
really important other main characters
like Tyrion and everyone would love to
see Tyrion on the Iron Throne but
remember the Iron Throne isn't the
ultimate goal it's all about the war for
the dawn Tyrion is serving tenaris right
now so in the narrative she's way more
important than he is so if any new
mythical champions are going to rise
it's gonna be like Daenerys and Jon Snow
Stannis it seems like the show you're
based on him killing Shireen it wants us
to feel like it's okay for him to die
like making him seem super crazy as a
way to clear the path emotionally for
the audience to feel like it's okay for
bran daram Oathkeeper through his face
so even if he does ultimately die then
Melisandre will just look for another
vision in the flames and see who they
select as the next champion just
remember though Melisandre has been
known to misinterpret her visions so
it's not like her magic
is a concrete roadmap for the future so
here's my big question for you guys in
the context of the series when you look
at like season six seven eight you know
however many seasons it gets do you
think that we'll see characters right
now be chosen as the new champions of
light and dark if you ever saw that
second Pirates of the Caribbean movie
will kills the captain of the Flying
Dutchman it serves this grand cosmic
purpose of ferrying souls from the world
of the living to the world of the dead
so it must have a captain if you kill
the captain you have to take his place
so if the night's king in azor Ahai died
someone has to take their place that
being said we just met the night's king
I don't think we're gonna see him
anytime soon the show wants us to feel
like he is this grand terrible figure
killing him off in the finale would
completely undercut that so if there's
gonna be a new night's king on the show
we probably won't meet him for a long
time Zhora High though is a completely
different story
it's just that collectively I feel like
the audience right now really wants to
stand us to die in the most horrible way
imaginable
so I know you guys would be excited
about this but I have another signed
copy of a feast for crows it's signed by
George R Martin it's a hardback I'm
gonna give it away in my finale video so
be sure to subscribe to get that I'll
also be doing another bonus video on
Sunday so if you have any requests for
that just leave them in the comments
whenever we do get to the finale I'll
announce what my bonus video schedule is
going to be for the rest of the summer
and I will continue to do a weekly
giveaway so well you guys wait for that
to post you can click here to learn all
about a shy the place that Melisandre
comes from ant you can click here for my
episode 9 video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you